yes thank you yes sir we have John Sayer
with us for the first time uh welcome
John said you had quite a difficult
start in this tournament and before we
analyzed the game a little bit I wanted
to ask you uh well how do you feel
because it seems like after you lose
well first three games it seems that
I personally think I will never win
again so uh tell us a little bit about
how you feel well yeah I mean it's it's
not good when you start tournament with
a losing three games but I mean okay
happens I didn't play for a while my
last tournament was in the
February played in Munich
so yeah
I don't know I'm just trying to stay
positive
there was a very important of all event
in your life you got married you know
after the Grand Prix so do you think uh
well it will have an impact on your play
we we were talking about my son
Grandmaster were losing 50 points
somewhere winning 50 points no I think
okay maybe for now I'll lose them but
then I mean I'll get them back for sure
if I want it but okay now I'm busy with
other stuff but I'm sure I'll be back so
it's fine does your husband support you
during the tournament he follows the
games yeah he follows the games even
though we have like 11 hours difference
so it's very important for me that he's
very supportive and also it's not easy
because I mean I think I'm staying here
for like two weeks already uh yeah no
easy to not see each other you know but
it's fine okay okay so today you you
drew against Elizabeth pets how
difficult it is to play against your
friend first of all
well I honestly I don't like to play
against my friends because usually you
know you're you're kind to them
I don't know what to do with it so yeah
it's kind of my weaknesses so I don't
like yes to play against my friends and
okay I'm trying to be like not that
aggressive okay so but you chose the
Greenfield today it's one of the most
aggressive openings but yeah but okay I
mean for the last time I didn't work
much and the Greenville is my main
opening so I thought like okay why not
to play the old stuff okay so here were
you surprised by the line that Elizabeth
uh choose today I think how far did you
know here to to which point I I'm not
sure if I remembered my line but I saw
some games maybe like years ago so I was
surprised after Bishop G5 I'm here yes I
I didn't know this move I knew that
there was some games of Arena crash I
think it was from the Olympiad and my
discussing yes after the game with
Elizabeth she also saw the game so she
wanted to surprise me with G5 but oh
yeah F3 Bishop G5
when I saw like taking on e4 and queen
A6 I think I was really fine with my
position because she she couldn't castle
and I thought like okay it's very
Dynamic and equal probably so it's fine
yes this this was played actually a few
times already and white I played Bishop
B7 several times in this position were
you considering this move yeah I was
checking I was checking some crazy line
with Rooker 4.
and I didn't know if it's like working
or not because then there is this idea
was okay for the sign you and I'm
looking at you and trying to give a maid
on A2 on A2 yes so maybe bishop F5 is
something like this yeah maybe this
looks normal
so you were feeling quite confident here
anyway yes after Knight E4 yeah that's
actually what I like from Greenfield
because it's it's dangerous but I think
that's my style so I like to play this
crazy amazing position so that's fine
and how did it go uh yes it was the
repetition of the repetition and a very
complex position
uh
and with the Perpetual check so
yeah I was thinking of King F1 and just
running but probably is also draw what
do you do after king of one let's check
if our computer says something yeah I
think yes we can take them
take the rook and you cannot Escape
so now that you've made the drawer
tomorrow you're going to be in a very
aggressive mood with white yeah against
Alexandra oh so you already know your
pairing so you've prepared a little bit
uh yeah I prepared a little also we were
playing last year in the Grand Prix in
Astana and I lost with white but I was
like really well prepared but she
surprised me with within one move and
then it just went wrong so hopefully
like tomorrow will be much better yeah
I think you should say you know we never
talk about our feelings our emotions so
you told us about the game that you lost
respite so are you seeking for Revenge
tomorrow
well maybe but it's it's uh this emotion
it can be very risky for me because I
mean I'm not in the best shape and if
you see my games like I'm trying to push
and yeah that's why I lost
Las Vegas
I don't know what will be tomorrow but
okay I'll try my best okay lots of luck
for tomorrow and I really hope to see
you once again thanks
indeed lots of luck as insaya turn